the uncertainty is overwhelming
despite the uninterrupted shelling
Ukrainian troops wait ready for what
will unfold next they stand by Vigilant
as hours turn to days near the border of
kharkif province
instead of cars barricades Now cover
roads that lead into the main city
the sound of shelling has become so
familiar
it's now part of the Soldier's daily
routine
the Russians are attacking us on a daily
basis but we're holding our own and
defending our ground we won't let the
enemy set foot here again
for months the Russians controlled this
territory along the border they
eventually left overpowered by Ukrainian
forces much of the area now Bears the
signs of War
abandoned villagers are now military
zones surrounded by the aftermath of
fierce fighting
Al Jazeera managed to go inside one of
Ukraine's barricades where attacks are
always a threat
the military posts were built by Russian
troops before they withdrew now they're
used by ukrainians who also make use of
the weapons left behind by their enemy
we are on the defensive but we're also
in total control we are defending our
skies and our land this here is an
anti-aircraft defense system we use it
to hunt them down
we are given access to only some of
these trenches where ukrainians are
developing new strategies but beyond a
certain point we're told filming must
stop
we dig ditches to hide from the enemy
and for protection from the Winter's
cold trenches are warmer especially if
we set a fire
digging ditches is exhausting work but
they're very useful military tools
most civilians have decided to stay away
from the area even after Russia's
withdrawal
because this post is so close to
Russia's border Ukrainian troops are in
a constant state of alert in a sense
expecting the unexpected they know their
Russian counterparts are likely carrying
out the same orders just a few hundred
meters away from them
along the Ukrainian Russian border